y economía en directo médico que ya está
conmigo en el estudio daniela brandon
dani bienvenida feliz cierre ya nuestro
último programa del año usted estábamos
discutiendo ahora porque dijo que se
vino navideña con este color yo digo que
no que el vix colores and johnson verde
y rojo pero eso es como un amarillo ocre
que para navidad o verde rojo blanco de
la nieve yo soy más tradicional creo muy
mal en colores así daltónico danny vamos
a empezar hablando de brasil porque
extendieron los incentivos para que las
empresas no despidan a sus empleados
bueno una noticia entonces para los
empleados de brasil y si actualmente
raúl está vigente una exención del
impuesto sobre la nómina para 17
sectores de la economía en diciembre de
este año expiraba ese beneficio y ahora
el senado de brasil lo extendió hasta
diciembre de 2023 como una medida para
salvar empleos el proyecto ya pasó por
la cámara baja sólo le falta la firma
del presidente que ayer bolsonaro como
es entonces este panorama laboral en
brasil bueno mire lo observamos con
cierre ser trimestre la tasa de
desempleo era de 12 6% una de las más
altas de la región aunque ha cedido
porque llegó hasta el 15 por ciento en
el peor momento de la pandemia eso
quiere decir que hay unos 13,5 millones
de desempleados en la primera economía
de américa latina ya varias empresas e
inclusive habían amenazado con más
despidos si no se aprobaba la extensión
de este beneficio tributario pero hasta
en el mismo ministerio de economía se
habían resistido porque cuesta casi 1500
millones de dólares al año
danny y eeuu se salvan en cumplir el
pago de sus deudas porque se salvó bueno
cada cierto tiempo usted lo sabe eeuu se
salva de irse a un incumplimiento de
deuda nacional de hecho nunca lo ha
hecho pues resulta que la única vez que
estuvo muy cerca fue en 2011 y eso
desató caos en los mercados esta vez
debido al gran endeudamiento que ha
tenido por cuenta de la pandemia el país
se estaba encaminando nuevamente a un
impago el próximo 15 de diciembre y la
única manera de evitarlo era que el
congreso autorizara un aumento en el
techo de deuda que hoy 28 9 billones de
dólares como algo casi impensable el
partido republicano acordó con sus
rivales demócratas no oponerse para
despejar el camino y suspender ese
límite qué quiere decir raúl que los
demócratas pueden autorizar al país a
que siga pagando sus deudas con una
mayoría simple sin necesidad del voto
republicano esto no le cayó muy bien
desde luego al ex presidente de donald
trump quien consideró que sus colegas
están rindiendo ante los demócratas
ahora lo que falta de la aprobación del
proyecto de ley final pero ya los
demócratas digamos que tienen casi
asegurada esta aprobación y seguimos en
eeuu porque la comercializadora de café
más grande del mundo está estrenando un
sindicato ya sabe usted de quién se
trata por supuesto me encanta starbucks
starbucks ajá pues este es uno de los
mayores empleadores sin sindicado en
eeuu lo era porque eso va a cambiar de
ahora en adelante los trabajadores de
dos locales de starbucks en buffalo que
queda en nueva york' crearon el primer
sindicato en los 50 años de historia de
la compañía eran tres locales en
votación pero sé esperando los otros
resultados uno de ellos lo rechazó y
estaba revisando el conteo escuchamos
queremos decirles star box esto no es lo
que eres destruir sindicatos no es de
esta empresa somos esta empresa y
estamos aquí habiendo tenido éxito a
pesar de todo lo que se hizo para evitar
esto durantes now the knack está penada
ahora el siguiente paso como dijo
michelle es llevar starbucks a la mesa
de negociaciones nos hemos ganado
nuestro puesto y hemos demostrado que
somos starbucks danny y con este
sindicato que viene ahora entonces para
esta empresa bueno starbucks se cuenta
con unos 9000 locales en todo eeuu y
había tratado de evitar la creación de
un sindicato durante meses diciendo que
poner un representante entre ellos y la
dirección traicionado a los principios
de la empresa y hacía todo más difícil
ahora se deben sentar a negociar un
acuerdo colectivo que podría marcar un
punto de inflexión para los trabajadores
en el resto de estas tiendas muy
visitadas por todos menos por mí porque
no le gusta el café yo no me puedo
quedar y viniendo de una colombiana por
favor danielle indicadores mire los
mercados asiáticos si quieren a wall
street a la baja
los inversionistas están concentrados en
el dato de inflación de eeuu y si nos
vamos para europa las bolsas operan
cautelosas a media jornada a la espera
de esta misma noticia que podría dar
luces sobre las decisiones que pueda
tomar la reserva federal próximamente y
para final para finalizar este bloque
económico que nos trae como cifra el día
compraría un carro chino
bueno
si no me gusta mucho los japoneses como
toyota bueno sí señor pues 252 millones
de vehículos vendidos en china en
noviembre de 2021 es la cifra del día la
caída del 9,1 por ciento en las ventas
frente a hace un año es la séptima
consecutiva en el mercado
automovilístico más grande del planeta y
se debe desde luego a la escases global
de semiconductores y precisamente
hablemos de china dani en nuestro
reportaje del día también chinos